now i would like to welcome dr chris
taylor he will be talking on the
bioinformatics research and education
for medical and graduate students dr
chris taylor's research lies in the
realm of computational biology and
bioinformatics
specifically related to
applications of high throughput
sequencing this research is highly
collaborative in nature involving the
development of algorithms for analysis
and visualization of sequencing data
over to you dr chris
all right um
let me get my screen share up
so
can you guys see my screen
yes doctor chris we can see our screen
all right great
um
so yes as uh mentioned um
i am an associate professor in the
department of microbiology immunology
and parasitology at louisiana state
health sciences in new orleans
it's the same institution that shindo
who you just heard speak is from
i also serve
as the director for the louisiana
biomedical research network's
bioinformatics biostatistics and
computational biology core
and that that network is headed up by
gus kasulis who spoke just before dr
jendo hicks
so thanks to uh the organizers and celia
for inviting me to speak
and i'm going to just discuss some of
the bioinformatics research and
education opportunities
that we have for medical and graduate
students and and how we
sort of uh address the the issues of
teaching bioinformatics in a medical
institution
all right so um
i'm actually my background is in
computer science so i got my
undergraduate
my master's and
my phd in computer science and during
the course of studying my phd
i transitioned into computational
biology and this was a time when
the human genome had was just being
finished being sequenced
and one of the things that was occurring
was that there were a lot of specialists
who were studying bioinformatics and
computational biology and they came from
all different backgrounds so some people
were from mathematics uh some from
computer science other from biology who
got into computation
and in in that time it was really
bioinformatics was very much of a niche
landscape where
there were a handful of these
specialized researchers but
nowadays nearly every discipline within
biomedical research has the needs for
bioinformatics methods
and we've really
narrowing this chasm between biology and
the computing sciences
and i i try to stand sort of in between
the two so that i can
interact with people on both sides
of these fields
so
the challenges that that i have run into
is that
as high throughput sequencing has come
onto the scene you know starting in 2005
through about 2008 getting established
and then in the last decade has really
exploded in the in the amount of
different things that you can use it for
because the cost of sequencing come down
so much
there's a plethora of sequencing data
that
needs to be analyzed
and it can't really be served anymore by
these niche
researchers in bioinformatics and
computational biology
so i've found that there's a need for
training biomedical researchers
particularly
to empower them to be able to perform
computational data analysis on their own
data
and those researchers really don't need
to be bioinformatics specialists anymore
they can actually be biomedical
researchers that learn enough to do
analysis of their own data
the problem that arises is really that
these researchers come from a diverse
set of backgrounds some of them have had
no computer programming experience
whatsoever
whereas others have been programming as
a hobby
you know for quite a bit of time
and so the traditional format or
educational programs where you you take
three people through step by step
can end up being
in a course setting
too fast for some of the people who
haven't had
this you know experience but can also be
incredibly slow for people who have had
that experience and so when you get one
of these courses
and you have these students with all
these varying backgrounds it's very
challenging to
to do a traditional lecture course
so the emerging solution that we've come
on to and and have partnered with pine
biotech in the louisiana biomedical
research network
is uh more of a reliance on technology
to provide online learning opportunities
which will allow students to move
individually at their own pace if they
can move really quickly through the
modules then they do them fast
and if they need to take some more time
they can take a bit more time and this
is really something that you can't
really accomplish in a traditional
in-person lecture format but with online
course modules
it allows people to move at their own
pace
and so
about four or five years ago i developed
uh these lecture series that i conducted
and i i conducted them in person at lsu
health sciences new orleans but we
recorded all of the lectures
using this media site capture technology
and we broadcast them also live
streaming for remote viewing for people
at lsu and other places throughout the
uh lbrn network
and then there was participation via
group forums for questions and
announcements and distribution of course
material and then we did some quizzes
and tests to
test the understanding of the material
and the idea behind this was always that
these these recorded lecture series
would persist and be available for
viewing on demand and so the two lecture
series that i gave in 2016 and 2017 are
still available
on my metagenomics search server at
one of them was a general introduction
to informatics
and the other was an introduction to
microbial community analysis and and
these are all available as slide sets
videos
on all the other lecture material is
available in archive
for download at those above urls
and interestingly uh you know some
unintended consequences occurred and i
got an email out of the blue
[Music]
from the northern new england clinical
and translational research network and i
guess they had done some searching and
they had happened upon
my lecture series and so they asked me
for permission
to link uh the lecture series for their
own investigators instead of you know
reinventing the wheel and so i think
this is you know one of the very
powerful aspects of of the online
learning paradigm is that you can reuse
these materials and and don't have to
continually reinvent the wheel and give
lecture after lecture on the same course
material
and
when we held these lecture series we
also throughout the lbrn network
provided them to our primarily
undergraduate institutes for usage and
um
they could
take the lectures that were recorded
online
and then they could add their own uh
sort of lan yap to them and so this was
done at both lsu shreveport in northern
louisiana and also at southern
university in baton rouge and they
enrolled students in courses at their
own university
and a lot of them were just topical
courses
and then they they allowed the students
to use the remote lecture material but
then the the instructor who was the
instructor of record at each individual
institution
would
partner and would provide in-person
lectures to supplement what the students
were learning
based on their needs
and so
that was done at those two institutions
and then since then the albertan has
partnered
with pine biotech and pine biotech
offers a whole library of courses that
are available online through their edu
platform
and
those are courses that students again
enroll in they take at their own pace
but then they're also if you're enrolled
in the alburn programs
are supplemented with some in-person
meetings that are done online as well
so this address is part of the critical
need for education in in the field of
bioinformatics
and so this pine biotech program it was
initially established in in the summer
of 2018 in that partnership
with pine biotech and the talbot
bioinformatics institute we had obtained
25 educational licenses as part of the
lbrn and we provided them to each of our
uh primarily undergraduate institution
campuses and they were able to enroll in
the fine biotech educational modules and
take them and so that pilot program went
so well
that um it's been expanded into a
full-blown partnership with biotech and
the students that take these uh these
modules on
genomics metagenomics transcriptomics
and and
other
topics they're encouraged to present
their their project posters at the lbr
and annual meeting and other uh other
meetings that are held a lot of them
virtually now due to the covet
restrictions
so that's been a large partnership that
has allowed the um you know
kind of expansion of the ability to to
teach bioinformatics
to
individuals who have very diverse
backgrounds and they can go at their own
pace through these course modules so
this is sort of been a whole evolution
over the past five or six years
and here's just a a snippet of the some
of the current offerings from those pine
biotech modules on transcripts
transcriptomics genomics metagenomics
and epigenomics and this is all opera
poe to the olmecs forum that we're that
we're going through right now
so one of the other things that i'll
draw your attention to is that as part
of the lbrn
and the
bioinformatics biostatistics and
computational biology core
that i direct we hold an annual
conference on bioinformatics and
computational biology every year
uh and we just held our eighth annual uh
conference the actual eighth annual
conference was originally scheduled for
april of 2020
but due to the emerging uh coveted 19
pandemic we had we didn't have time to
pivot and we actually had to cancel it
so we
we held our eighth annual conference
virtually uh april 15th to 17th
of this year
and we have
the uh recordings from all of the past
talks are available online through the
lbrm portal
on youtube
and the links are available at the uh at
the lbrn conference on
uh biology and bioinformatics
link above
and part of the the meeting that we held
just this year was a session that was
entirely organized was a whole day
organized by
todd reilly at the nih
center for information technology
and this was discussing the nih's
strides initiative which is a cloud
computing initiative
whereby they've partnered with amazon
web services research and google cloud
research and they provide training they
provide
cloud credits for researchers at embry
institutions
and we've been participating in a lot of
these trainings over the course the last
couple of months since they've been
established
and then we also had other imminent
bioinformatics and computational biology
speakers who covered topics across the
gamut of computational biology
including pandemic modeling
of covid19
the gut microbiome herpes simplex virus
and the role of statistics and
epigenetics research so this is just a
snapshot of all of our our primary
speakers
that we held at the 2021 uh conference
and the 2022 conference will be held
similarly will be held in april of 2022
so
keep an eye out that for that if you're
interested um
we're not sure quite yet whether it will
be a virtual format
whether it will be back to an in-person
format or some some form of hybrid
format so we'll see how that goes
so zooming in a little bit um that's a
lot of the initiatives that i'm evolving
involved with on a broader
scale
my own research lab at lsu health
sciences
when i built it back in 2012 i built it
with this open lab layout in order to
promote collaboration so we don't have
you know cubicles or partitions or
anything and i mean that was a great
idea back in 2012 maybe it's not such a
good idea nowadays
but the idea was that you know if
somebody's sitting there working on a
problem and they have an issue they
could turn to the person next to them
and see if they had some advice and so i
always have a mix of different
researchers in the lab at different
career stages i've had post-docs i've
had
graduate students i've had
undergraduates through our summer
research program i've even had high
school students through our summer
research program
and even a few uh junior faculty members
who wanted to come in
and learn how to analyze their own
biomedical research data
and so you know we work with them and
it's sort of this uh the old proverb of
if you give a man a fish you can eat for
a day but if you teach a man to fish you
can eat for a lifetime
so the idea is we teach these
researchers how to analyze their data
and then they they can kind of spread
their wings and and and do it on their
own in the future
and so i primarily in my own research i
work primarily with md phd students who
go through both our medical program and
our phd program and it's a joint program
and we just graduated vince maffie he
was an f30 fellow
working in alcohol research looking at
the gut microbiota
and i currently have in my lab
jacob elnager who's just submitted an
f30 grant which we hope will get funded
and he's working on
shotgun metagenomics analysis of the
vaginal microbiome with specific
emphasis on bacterial vaginosis
and then i've just hosted for a rotation
a student john lammons who did a
rotation this summer
and likely will join my lab as another
md phd student we've had several past
members of the lab as i said many
undergraduates several phd students who
work with other investigators have come
in and i've helped to co-mentor them if
they have a project in their home lab
that involves dna sequencing analysis
and so in terms of ongoing research
projects
my research really focuses in heavily
now on the vaginal microbiota and
various sexually transmitted infections
so i have a multi-pi uh
r01 grant that is studying the clearance
of chlamydia
prior to treatment so we have some women
who come in they get tested for
chlamydia they end up positive by the
time we call them back in for treatment
they've actually cleared the chlamydial
infection
through natural host defense and we're
looking at the
you know properties of the microbiome
that potentially promote
that natural clearance
prior to antibiotic treatment we've also
got a
a new ro1 that's based in south africa
and is joined with the university of
cape town and the university of southern
california
and that's looking at
adverse birth and newborn outcomes and
the interaction of the vaginal
microbiome with
preterm birth and adverse birth outcomes
then there's a an r01 that i have um
with a collaborator at uab christina
mosney to study bacterial vaginosis
and my student jacob the f30 that he
submitted is really working uh jointly
under that grant
i'm also a member of the center for
clinical and translational research at
uab
uh lsu health sciences is one of the sub
sites for that so that's this ul one
grant and then we're doing some work on
the gut microbiota and precision
medicine under a uh-2 grant
and we just got a an r21 got a fundable
score last month that this is going to
be kind of an interesting one we're
going to look at transgender men
who are just initiating testosterone use
and we're going to look at how that
impacts
the vaginal and reproductive tract
microbiota and the
propensity for getting bacterial
vaginosis after testosterone use
and then
as i mentioned i'm also part of the
louisiana biomedical research network
and more recently we've gotten an nsf
grant funded for a high performance
computing cluster so we're we're just
into the start of the second year for
that
and that grant has supported the
acquisition of a a
large computing cluster which we call
tiger fish
and it's one of the fir it's actually
the first high performance computing
that has been broadly available for our
health sciences center campus in new
orleans we've had access to
some of the clusters in um in baton
rouge and through the loaning network
but
this is for
new orleans specifically and it provides
up to 193 teraflops of compute
1400 total compute cores
it's primarily composed of these compute
nodes each of which has 192 gigabytes of
ram
but it also has available a large memory
node which has up to 1.5 terabytes of
ram available
for tasks that really need a lot of uh
of memory to perform their their compute
and so we just rolled this out we got
this cluster in april of 2021 and we're
you know we've got a bunch of users
using it for all kinds of things my
lab's using it cendo is a co-pi on this
grant his lab is using it
also carmen canaver is using it for some
computational neurobiology
and i'm you know in the interest of time
i'm not going to say much about this
because chennai covered the masters
program in bioinformatics that's been
initially it is being initiated to lsu
health sciences
and you've already got the link
to that bioinformatics program
and lastly i'll say that i'm one of the
founding members of the microbial
genomics resource group at lsu health
sciences and so you know if you follow
that link
um this is it's essentially it operates
sort of like a core but
we're not really a core so we just call
us ourselves a resource group
and it consists of myself in charge of
the bioinformatics david welsh who's a
pulmonary
medical doctor
and hmong
who does all of our sequencing prep and
sequencing and then a variety of
post-docs and students who work with us
but we have um on this website you know
we have a lot of our joint publications
and everything but down near the bottom
and also accessible via this link
is uh you know our cost and our sample
submission so we do a lot of microbial
genomics because we have an aluminum i
seek and so you know we do a lot of
microbial community analysis and we're
just starting to get into some shotgun
metagenomics as well
and so that's pretty much all i have to
say and you know if there's any time for
questions i'm happy to answer any
questions
all right great thank you